what do you think makes a great leader
maybe if you have other examples
throughout history
and great again let's lose that use that
term
loosely now he's going to ask for a
definition great
uniter of whether it's evil or good
it doesn't matter is there somebody who
stands out to you alexander the grace
talking about military or
you know some people bring up fdr or or
i mean it could be the founding fathers
of this country
or we can go to uh was he mana
uh man of the century up there hitler of
uh the 20th century and stalin and these
people had
really uh amassed the amount of power
that probably has never been seen in the
history of the world
is there somebody who stands out to you
by way of uh trying to define what makes
a great uniter
great leader in one man or a woman maybe
in the future
it's an interesting question and one
i've thought a lot about because let's
take alexander the great as an example
because alexander fascinated the world
of his time fascinated
ever since people have been fascinated
with the guy but alexander was
a hereditary monarch right yeah he he
was
handed the kingdom which is fascinating
right but he did not need
to rise from nothing to get that job in
fact he reminds me of a lot of other
leaders of frederick the great for
example
in prussia these are people who
inherited
the greatest army of their day
alexander unless he was in imbecile was
going to be
great no matter what because i mean if
you inherit the vermont
you're going to be able to do something
with it right alexander's father
may have been greater philip uh he
philip ii was the guy
who who literally did create uh a
a strong kingdom from a disjointed
group of people that were continually
beset by their neighbors he's the one
that reformed that army
uh took things that he had learned from
other uh greek leaders like the theban
leader at pemenandez
um and then laboriously
over his lifetime stabilized the
frontiers built this system
he lost an eye doing it he he he his leg
was made lame
i mean he this was a man who looked like
he built the empire and
led from from the front ranks i mean um
so and then
and then who may have been killed by his
son we don't know who assassinated
philip
um but then handed the greatest army the
world had ever seen to his son
who then did great things with it uh you
see this this pattern
many times so in my mind i'm not sure
alexander really can be that great
when you compare him to people who arose
from nothing so the difference between
what we would call in the united states
the self-made man or the one who
inherits a fortune
there's an old line that you know it's
it's a slur but uh it's about rich
people and it's like he was born on
he was born on third base and thought he
hit a triple
right um philip was born at home plate
and he had to hit alexander
started on third base and so i try to
draw a distinction
between them genghis khan is tough
because there's two traditions
the tradition that we grew up with here
in the united states and that i grew up
learning was that he was a self-made man
but there is a tradition and it may be
one of those things that's put after the
fact because a lot a long time ago
whether or not you had blue blood in
your veins was an
important distinction and so the
distinction that you'll often hear from
mongolian history
uh is that this was a a nobleman who had
been deprived of his inheritance so he
was a blue blood anyway
i don't know which is true uh there's
certainly i mean when you look at a
genghis khan though you have to go
that is a wicked amount of things to
have achieved
uh he's very impressive as a figure
attila is very impressive as a figure
um hitler's an interesting figure he's
one of those people
you know the more you study about hitler
the more you wonder where
the defining moment was because um
if you look at his life i mean hitler
was a relatively
common soldier in the first world war i
mean he was brave he got uh
he got some decorations in fact the
highest decoration he got in the first
world war was given to him by a jewish
officer and it was uh he often didn't
talk about that decoration even though
it was the more prestigious one because
it would open up a whole can of worms
you didn't want to get into
but hitler's i mean if you said who was
hitler today
one of the top things you're going to
say is he was an anti-semite
well then you have to draw a distinction
between general
regular anti-semi-semitism that was
pretty common in the era
and something that was a rabid level of
anti-semitism but hitler didn't seem to
show a
rabid level of anti-semitism until after
or at the very end of the first world
war
so if this is a defining part of this
person's character
and and much of what we consider to be
his his evil
stems from that what happened to this
guy when he's an adult
right he's already fought in the war to
change him so i mean it's almost like
the old there was always a movie theme
somebody gets
hit by by something on the head and
their whole personality changes right
i mean it almost seems something like
that so i don't think i call that
necessarily a great leader
to me the interesting thing about hitler
is what the hell happened to a
non-descript person who didn't really
impress anybody
with his skills and then in in the 1920s
it's all of a sudden
as you said sort of the man of the hour
right so that to me is kind of fast i
have this
feeling that genghis khan and we don't
really know was an
impressive human being from the get-go
and then he was raised in this
environment with pressure on all sides
so you you start with this diamond and
then you polish it and you harden it his
whole life
hitler seems to be a very unimpressive
gemstone
most of his life and then all of a
sudden so i mean
i don't think i can label great leaders
and and i'm always fascinated by that
idea that
and i'm trying to remember who the quote
was by that that great men oh lord acton
so great men
are often not good men uh and that
in order to be great you would have to
jettison many of the moral
qualities that we normally would
consider a jesus or a gandhi or
you know the martial these these
qualities that one looks at as
as the good upstanding moral qualities
that we should all aspire to as examples
right the buddha whatever it might be
um those people wouldn't make good
leaders because what you need to be a
good leader often requires the kind of
choices
that a true philosophical diogenes moral
man
wouldn't make yeah um so i don't have an
answer to your question how about that
that's a very long way of saying i don't
know
just linger a little bit it does feel
like from my
study of hitler that the time molded the
man
versus genghis khan where it feels like
he
the man molded his time yes and i feel
that way about a lot of those nomadic uh
confederacy builders
that they really seem to be these
figures that
that stand out as extraordinary for one
in one way or another and remembering by
the way that almost all the history of
them were written by the enemies that
they so mistreated that they were
probably never going to get any good
press they didn't write
themselves that's a caveat we should
always yeah basically nomadic or native
american peoples or tribal peoples
anywhere
generally do not get the advantage of
being able to write the history of their
heroes
you